I'm Jonathan Brower and I'm a Scoutmaster with Troop 19 in Fort Wayne, Indiana.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Thank you for all your insight and your experience. You helped me be a better Scoutmaster.
And now for you, Scoutmaster.
Sensitivity is an important character trait. It's part of being a good person-
being friendly and kind and courteous and respectful, And as much a part of a good, strong
character as sensitivity is. it's not going to do you much good if it's not backed up by some resilience.
You also have to be resilient, don't you? It's just something I was thinking about.
Hey, this is podcast number 330..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green. Last week we talked about
maripazes and I predicted that a lot of people would get back to me, and a lot of people got
back to me. So let's go to the mailbag and replies to last week's podcast.
Jim Hilliard said: too many maripages feel like school Scouts are already in school all day
and the last thing they want to be doing on a weekend night is sitting down in classroom
formation doing more schoolwork, unless it's a topic that really interests them.
But even then, let's put the fun back into maripages. Let's learn by doing,
experiencing and practicing. Christian said. I find myself torn on this whole thing.
Some of the scouts are truly motivated by the badges and the work that goes into them.
Some could care less about the industrial complex that maripages have become.
Every scout is motivated differently And in the end, as you often state, Clark, the goal
is to build character in the boys. I would rather work with the system as it is
and try to motivate all the scouts in their own way. Well, Christian, it is a conundrum
And I want to go back to what Baden Powell had to say about advancement and badges and things like
that. What we're looking for is a way to get all the scouts along, Everybody along. And yeah,
And of course scouts are motivated by different things. But my whole argument about maripages
is they've just become something that doesn't look like scouting anymore.
Evan got in touch and said: I recently started counseling maripages. I became an eagle in 2006..
And I see how the focus on maripages detracts from some of the benefits of summer camp.
I like what you talked about in the World Organization, the scouting movements wrap
program. I agree that changing that kind of system is highly unlikely,
but I wonder what your thoughts are about how a change like that could be accomplished.
And, Evan, I got to say I don't have any thoughts.
The organization that most of us are members of, the BSA, is solidly run by adults And most of
them are men. Most of them are over the age of 30. And I think basically there's zero chance that
there's going to be any substantive change to all this. If we had any kind of youth
government as a part of our organization above the unit level, I think things might
be a little different. but that's not going to happen. And I know I'm sounding really negative,
but I don't really see a way out of the situation or seeing any sweeping changes
being made. It's so baked into our concept of scouting that I think it eclipses reason.
Philip got in touch to say maripages have become the tail that wags the dog.
In order to get them, a scout has to do the opposite of what the program is supposed to do.
That's a very good thought, Philip. Instead of being part of a patrol in a troop,
he spends his time working alone on requirements. Instead of being outdoors, he's indoors
writing reports and building displays. They should be de-emphasized. And Philip notes
that will never happen And the emphasis put on part of being in a patrol or a troop,
leading and following, learning to work with people And, more importantly,
the emphasis put on fun. Good memories are one of the best assets to own. I'm going to say that again
because I think that's a great thought, Philip. Good memories are one of the best assets to own.
I don't think that all of this has happened purposefully. I just think that when people
think of Boy Scouts, they think of a sash full of maripages. It's something tangible that
can be measured. Well, Philip, I appreciate those thoughts. Dennis Unger got in touch and
said the soapbox moment in the last podcast was really inspiring. These are things that need to
be addressed. I was a scout in the 1980s and we focused on skills and maripages were second.
Bill Daniel commented: summer camp has seemed wrongheaded to me for some time. Are there any
camps that make advancement or maripages the almost accidental byproduct of a great adventure?
Not to my knowledge, Bill. there are probably isolated parts of camp programs
where you have a set of counselors that really get that. the idea is to go out and have fun and
then maybe look at the fun that you had and say, oh, we earned a maripage too, But what's
baked in is just this approach, that is, a school approach, because that's what everybody knows.
It's the easiest thing to do, isn't it? It's the least challenging way to get all this done.
when we look at the mountain of work, of maripages that you have to do as a scout if you want
to become an Eagle Scout, The easiest way to get it done is just to set up a school.
Makes sense. I don't like it, but it makes perfect sense. So the most sensible approach
is not always the scouting approach, is it? You may quote me?
Oh hey, we had a nice live chat session this week and, in addition to all of the frequent
flyers, they checked in- we heard from Don, who is a Wolf-Dan leader with PAC 791 in Hopkinsville,
Kentucky, Scott, who is a scout master, Elaine, who is working with a BSA troop in London, England,
And Mike Summers checked in during the chat and he's a scout master with Troop 89 in Wilson,
North Carolina. If you want to join us for a live chat, keep an eye on our Facebook feeds
and our Twitter feed, because I'll always announce when we're going to be live at scoutmastercgcom for
a chat. These will happen most of the time on Tuesday and or Wednesday mornings. I want to take a
moment and pause here to thank all the folks who are scoutmastercgcom backers, especially Ed
Graytricks and Constance Ryan, who added their names to the list of backers since our last podcast.
I want to say thanks, too, to all of you who've added their support, to the many folks who helped
make the blog and podcast possible through something called Patreon. Now, if you'd like to
become a backer or join our Patreon subscribers, visit scoutmastercgcom. You'll find links
to follow at the top right of any page on the website and links in this episode's podcast notes.
And, speaking of this episode, we've got a bunch of email questions to answer. We're still
chipping away at the giant backlog of email questions. So let's get started, shall we?
Oh, Mr Johnson had troubles of his own. He had a yellow cat that wouldn't leave his home.
He tried and he tried to get a cat away. He gave it to a man going far, far away,
but the cat came back the very next morning. Yeah, the cat came back. the very next day.
The cat came back. They thought it wasn't gonna, but the cat came back. It just couldn't stay away.
Away,
Away.
Email, that is folks. And here's an answer to one of your emails,
Email question number one. This one will remain anonymous. The author wrote:
I am a unit commissioner and our scout master called me and told me his senior patrol leader
had sexually harassed a teacher at school and had been suspended for holding a broom like a machine
gun. Wow, Okay. The young man apologized to the teacher, accepted his punishment. The scout master
then proceeded to tell me he thought he should fire the senior patrol leader for conduct on
becoming a scout. What's your take on the situation? This sort of situation is something
I get asked about quite often And forgive me if you've heard answers to this sort of thing
recently, but since the question keeps coming up, I think the answer can keep going out: How
do we react to events in a scout's life outside of scouting? Now, if those events, if they've done
something that evidences a real and present danger to their fellow scouts, we're gonna
have to handle them differently than the things that were described in the question asked in
this email. And in the event that there is something that puts the question of whether
or not it is safe to have a given scout involved in our activities, then the best thing to do is to
back off, tell the scout and his family. until all of these issues are resolved and all of the processes
play out around them, we're really we're going to ask you not to actively participate at this
point, And I've had to do that before once in 30 years, so it's not a very common thing.
What's more common is something like this: A scout has some kind of trouble outside of
scouting, is dealing with the consequences of those we take notice of and we say: well,
you know, how can this guy be a senior patrol leader? It's conduct. I'm becoming a scout.
Well, you know, look, we do our best when we go back to the simpler principles involved.
So what is our job? Our job is to help young people grow in character, And there's a number of
associated issues in accomplishing this, but any action we take should be aimed at getting our
job done, aimed at the growth of character. A scout master is not the boss of a company. I will say
that again. A scout master is not the boss of a company with youth leaders who are his or her
employees, whom we discipline or hire and fire. They are scouts selected by their fellow scouts
to lead them. So the idea of firing- quote unquote- a senior patrol leader is silly, because that's not
the relationship that we have with our youth leadership. A scout master is not the commanding
officer. Let me say it again: A scout master is not the commanding officer and his youth leaders
are his soldiers, who he can discipline for- quote- conduct unbecoming a scout unquote. That's
an equally foolish idea. Let's get that out of our heads as well. Scouters and scout masters hold a
unique role in a young person's life. if they understand their job properly, They are part
parent, part coach, part counselor, part mentor and friend. We are not a boss. We are not a
commanding officer. If an event like the one that was described in this email comes to our attention,
how should we approach it? understanding our role and understanding the goal of our work?
We're dealing with people at an inherently unstable time of their lives, and a young
person's actions can certainly be out of sync with their own highest and best. and I
bet you, if you think about it for 30 seconds, you can recall an instance in your own young life
when this was the case, when you did something that you regret it Now. how the people in our lives
reacted to those incidents is a key part of the formation of our character When you're talking
about the administration of a school. they have a limited spectrum of responses to this sort of thing.
They have rules and regulations that they're obligated to follow. On the other hand, in
scouting we have a set of guiding principles in the oath and law that we can apply with
compassion and friendship and kindness to individual situations. Of course, as I said when we began
talking about the answer to this particular email, there are policies and procedures to follow
when the actions of a scout rise to the level of concern for the safety and well-being of
other scouts. but that's not the situation we're talking about here. We're talking about
a young person who's gone and done something inadvisable and stupid, probably really deeply
regrets having done it, has already apologized for it happened outside of scout. so what are we
going to do? Well, given that kind of a scenario, I would sit down with the scout and I would ask
him some questions. I would ask him what happened. I would ask him why he thought this
happened. I would ask him what parts of the scout oath and law bear on the situation. I would
ask him how it affects their ability to maintain a position of responsibility and be a leader by
example in the troop. I would ask them what actions they're planning to take, so far as the
scouts are concerned, in resolving this issue. Does he think there's anything he needs to
say to people? Does he think that this whole thing necessitates some kind of explanation
to the scouts and their families? and none of these questions are rhetorical. They are true,
open-ended questions. I want to know what's going on and I believe the resulting conversation would
suggest some ways forward with the scout, and I know it certainly would get them exercising that
internal standard that we call character. that's based on the scout oath and law. Now, if I reacted
to the situation as you described by issuing a judgment and I thought that I was the boss of
the scout and I could fire him, or I thought I was the commanding officer of the scout and I could
bring him up on charges for conduct, I'm becoming, I would deny the scout and myself the significant
opportunity to better understand exactly what the scout oath and law mean. There are situations
where our response is defined by various policies and rules, and those are rare
and serious situations, but the one that is described in this email, I think, is clearly a
judgment call. I've never been disappointed when I apply my judgment to the best interest of
the individual scout by seizing the opportunity to help them examine and develop their character.
and the fringe benefit of this is examining and developing my own character and my own skills
as a scouter. I got this email from Jim Manson and he asked: do troop fundraisers count as
service hours? If our troop has a booth at a local event to sell refreshments and scouts work
at it, does it count as service hours? Well, so you need to fill in a little more information
here. who's the service being rendered to and where will the funds be spent? If their troop has a
booth at a local event and they sell refreshments and you keep the profits, it benefits the scouts
themselves. so that's not really service to others, is it? If you have that booth and the
profits are being given to a community organization, that's service to others. So Jim replied: what
if a scout does trail maintenance for a Boy Scout property? should that count as service hours?
Again, you ask the same question: who does the service benefit? Is the benefit limited to just
his troop, to the scout himself or to the wider community? So if you go out and you raise funds
for your troop, part of that fundraising accrues directly to the scout's personal benefit, right,
and so I would not count that as as service to others. that's self-serving. I guess you could
probably say that doing the trail work accrues to the benefit of the scout in some ways, but it
also accrues to the benefit as his member of a broader community, a scout. so I say, yeah, that that
sounds like service to others. to me, The bigger issue here is the idea of doing service work is
not getting credit for it, but forming habits of service to others that will follow a scout
throughout their lifetime, right? So hopefully, service to others is emphasized in each troop
to the point where there's no real question of fulfilling the hours required, where there's
no real question of a scout having to go. geez, you know, I need three hours of service to get my next
rank. what can I do? well, no, this is something that we do all the time. If a scout for some reason
wasn't able to participate in different service projects that a troop was doing, he could certainly
go out and do his own, his own service hours. He could go out and do something nice for other
people. He can grab a trash bag and a pair of gloves and a high visibility vest and walk
around his neighborhood and pick up trash. He can go across the street with a rake and rake leaves
for that older couple that has a little trouble getting around. He can volunteer for any number of
community organizations to help them accomplish their work. Service is not something that you get
credit for as a rank. service is a way of life. you look after other people, you take care of
their concerns, you help. you know that's that's being a scout. Our scout should be good,
active, contributing members of their community right now. we don't have to wait till their adults.
they can be that right now. so the question of service hours: that should be the easiest one
in that whole set of requirements. I heard from Brian Kerner who's asked: can you provide
a definition for the life rank requirement which requires conservation related service hours? I can't
seem to find any definition published by the BSA. Aha, well, Brian, I wrote about this a while back
when the new rank requirements came out. I'll have a link to the post that I'm talking about
in the podcast notes for this episode. Here's what the life requirement reads. it says: while a star
scout participate in six hours of service through one or more service projects approved by your
scout master, at least three hours of this service must be conservation related. I noted at the time
when I first read this that specifying three hours of conservation related projects
is a good idea, but it will become one of those questions that are going to come up all the time
and the probably the source of some argument. I would have worded it differently. I would have said
three hours of service and three hours of conservation work, and I would have provided
definitions. but there's no definition that I know of. so it's pretty simple, right, if we read the
requirement, who approves these service projects? the scout master does, so whatever the scout master
defines as conservation related is going to be approved work towards that requirement.
Here's the fourth and last email question for this episode of the scout master podcast. boy,
we're setting them up and knocking them down today, aren't we? and this comes from Robert Grimes, who
says: I'm a new scout master for a BSA troop in Madrid, Spain. I was wondering: should scouts use
the mister honorific when addressing the scout master and assistant scout masters?
scouting is one of the few places that manners are observed. scouting is one of the few places that
manners are observed. I hope that's not the case, however, Robert goes on to say: I want to be
approachable, I don't want to hinder interaction with authority figures. I am I am aware that
respect is something that is earned and not bestowed simply by a title, but the scouts are
addressing their elders and I wonder what you had to say about that. well, I you know, I began as a
fairly young scout master and the scouts always have called me by my first name and it hasn't changed
in 35 years. I have had other nicknames when I was a camp counselor and when I was a coach.
you know, it all worked for me. manners and respect are a two-way street. if you want to be called
mr Grimes, address all the scouts the same way. mr Jones, mr Smith, you know things like that.
I would also have the grace never to correct anyone on a matter of manners, because that to me is
unmanorly. I mean, I would just model the manners that you expect. if you model the behavior in
the manners that you expect, your scouts will reply in kind. and if you don't set yourself up as a
constant judge in a pain about exactly how things ought to be in your mind, you will be modeling the
gracious, good manners I think that you intend. in the end, I don't have a whole lot of preference
about what my scouts call me. some of them do use mr, some of them just use my first name.
it doesn't really matter to me, just so long as they don't call me late for supper, right, hey, if you
have a question or a comment, you can get in touch. it's very simple to do and I'm going to tell you
how to do that in just a moment. thank you so much for listening to this 330th edition of the scout
master podcast. now here's how to keep in touch. if you go to scoutmastercgcom, you'll find 1600
articles and over 300 editions of the podcast and while you're there, you can subscribe to receive
updates to the blog and the podcast by email. you can follow us in the vast panorama of social media
outlet. over 15,000 folks follow us at scoutmaster blog on facebook, where you're much more than
just a face in the crowd. we have an ever-growing chorus of tweeters on twitter who typed truly
tremendous, thoughtful tweets. we pinned the paltritudinous pictures proffered publicly with a
parcel of prolific printers on pinterest, and you can always watch us at scoutmastercg on youtube.
but if you can't face facebook and twitter tends to make you better. if you've no interest in pinterest
and you don't put the? u in youtube, that's okay, i understand. here's what you do. old codger, zoom
into the late 90s and send me an email. yep, dust off that old desktop system. log into your aol account.
if you don't have one, i've got a cd. you can use an email me. i'm clark green and you can get in
touch with me anytime at clark at scoutmastercgcom. c, l, a, r, k, e at scoutmastercgcom. if all else
fails, take a look around your stately manor home and there you will find a bronze bust of
shakespeare. it's right there in the library on the desk. there's a button inside that that will
open up a secret passageway. slide down the bat pole in that passageway and i will be waiting for you
in the bat game by now. it should be abundantly clear that the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster
podcast are not official publications of anyone in particular other than myself. i am not endorsed
or sponsored by the boyscouts of america or any other scouting organization for that matter. it's
just me. i have a microphone, a way to get online and people actually listen to this podcast, which
is still kind of amazing to me. and i am doing it to lend a hand to my fellow scouts and have a
little bit of fun along the way. and speaking of fun, here he is our founder, sir robert bidden. pal,
sir robert, good luck to you and good camping. oh, i thank you, sir, until next time, everyone.